gibt es eine ganze menge vor der sitzung
des bundestages morgen und deshalb gebe
ich jetzt direkt ab zu erhard scherfer
nach berlin
vielen dank an dieser stelle ja sind in
der tat zwei schwerpunkte im die uns
heute bei den stellungnahmen der
fraktionsspitzen immer wieder begegnet
sind da ist auf der einen seite
natürlich der krieg gegen die ukraine
und die folgen daraus wir haben ja seit
einigen tagen eine sogenannte
entlastungs debatte da gibt es
unterschiedliche vorschläge die im raum
stehen und die reaktionen darauf die
wären wir gleich in der nächsten drei
viertelstunden immer mal wieder hören
und das andere große thema weil es mit
zwei gleiche drei wichtigen
tagesordnungspunkt noch eine große rolle
spielen wird in dieser sitzungswoche im
bundestag das ist das thema corona
maßnahmen und da werden wir sehen dass
auf der einen seite das
infektionsschutzgesetz das am freitag ja
dann abschließend hier noch mal
abgestimmt werden soll beziehungsweise
die änderungen daran eine große rolle
spielen wird und auch die impfpflicht
wird am donnerstag zum ersten mal im
deutschen bundestag diskutiert werden
insbesondere die gruppenanträge werden
da eine große rolle spielen und die ja
unterschiedliche vorhaben und maßnahmen
vorsehen und das mag ein ganz
wesentlicher grund dafür gewesen sein
dass rolf mützenich der vorsitzender der
spd-fraktion mit diesem thema seine
stellungnahme heute mittag auch begonnen
hat
die anderen themen sind natürlich dass
der einen seite wir eine offene debatte
im deutschen bundestag zumindest wenn
man die
koalitionsfraktionen sieht zur
allgemeinen impfpflicht führen werden
die cdu csu hat nach meiner kenntnis ich
heute entschieden als fraktionen doch
diese debatte zu führen was sie nach
meinem dafürhalten nicht daran hindern
sollte in der zweiten und dritten lesung
den abgeordneten weil es eine
gewissensentscheidung ist dann auch die
möglichkeit einzuräumen
entsprechend der individuellen
überzeugung auch abstimmen zu können
wir werden uns nach der ersten lesung
eng zusammensetzen und versuchen eben
auch die unterschiedlichen ansichten
zusammenzuführen auf der anderen seite
aber das infektionsschutzgesetz auf der
tagesordnung wo wir innerhalb der
koalition aber auch der bundesregierung
ein
infektionsschutzgesetz auf den weg zu
bringen was auch dem entspricht was 16
bundesländer auf der letzten
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz von uns
erwartet haben als gesetzgeber nämlich
einen basisschutz in einem
infektionsschutzgesetz noch weiterhin
aufrecht zu erhalten sie wissen und das
muss ich respektieren dass ein
koalitionspartner hier offensichtlich
andere ansichten hat über das
infektionsgeschehen und die notwendigen
restriktionen die wir glauben weiterhin
auch in deutschland sehen zu müssen sehr
finde ich vorsichtige maßnahmen die aber
aufgrund der erfahrung durchaus helfen
können das infektionsgeschehen auch
einzudämmen der zweite punkt oder der
dritte punkt ist dann natürlich die
ansprache des ukrainischen präsidenten
im deutschen bundestag am donnerstag um
9 uhr wo er wie in anderen parlamenten
nämlich meines wissens im europäischen
parlament im britischen unterhaus zum
beispiel eben auch noch mal gerade in
diesem überfall
russlands auf einen souveränen staat
auch die partnerschaft gerade auch zu
ländern der europäischen union und der
nato auch pflegen will und wenn er den
ort des deutschen bundestages des
deutschen parlaments sucht so eröffnen
wir ihnen natürlich insbesondere in
diesen bedrohlichen stunden noch mal
dieses dieser öffentliche adresse der
letzte punkt entschuldung das ist jetzt
so lange es aber der letzte punkt sind
natürlich die entlastungsschritte die
wir auf der einen seite in dieser woche
in erster lesung nämlich die abschaffung
der eeg-umlage wo wir uns im
koalitionsausschuss damals darauf
verständigt haben ich glaube vor drei
wochen jetzt
heizkostenzuschuss und viele andere
dinge auch ein mehreren milliarden
schweres 15 milliarden schweres
entlastungsprogramm dennoch wollen die
bundesbürgerinnen und bundesbürger
antworten auf die aktuellen situation
nicht nur an den zapfsäulen sondern die
sich wahrscheinlich auch demnächst in
der heizkostenabrechnung und ähnliches
tun wird ich will für meine fraktion
erst mal bemerken dass wir schon finden
und das ist auch an die adresse der
bundesregierung insbesondere den
wirtschafts und finanzminister gerichtet
ob hier nicht offenkundig tauch
spekulationen am markt getätigt werden
weil wir sehen ja überhaupt nicht dass
das angebot zurzeit massiv reduziert
worden ist sondern im gegenteil sie sind
spekulationen an der am benzinpreis auch
erfolgs die einen massiven aufwuchs dann
auch an den zapfsäulen
vergegenwärtigen ich finde schon
zumindest muss das rechtlich noch mal
geprüft werden aber andererseits ist das
was der bundesfinanzminister
relativ freihändig in die debatte
gebracht hat am sonntag durchaus ein
aspekt wo man möglicherweise wenn er
denn umsetzbar ist wir haben ja schon
zurückhaltung was die
tankstellenbetreiber
betrifft ein weg sein könnte aber das
betrifft nicht insbesondere die gruppen
die sozial auf zusätzliche unterstützung
angewiesen sind und ob wir sozusagen
alle gleich an dieser frage auch
beteiligen ist natürlich für eine partei
die insbesondere für den sozialen
zusammenhalt versucht politik zu machen
und auch politisch zu entscheiden
durchaus eine berechtigte frage die wir
dann auch gleich in der fraktionssitzung
ansprechen werden vielen dank kommission
frank henkel
wenn sie sich direkt anschließend der
lindner vorschlag so dennig jährige
jetzt mache deren volumen von rund 6,6
milliarden müssen wir uns darauf
einstellen stellen sie sich darauf ein
dass das gesamtvolumen der entlastung
auch für andere gruppen dann in höheren
zweistelligen milliardenbetrag gehen
kann dass wir die eine frage und die
zweite zur ukraine sind ja drei
osteuropäische ministerpräsidenten jetzt
nach kiew geflogen ist das eigentlich
ein schritt den sie begrüßen weil es
eine zusätzliche
signal an die ukraine ist oder ehren
gefahrenmoment weil er auf dieser reise
auch was passieren könnte und er trinke
ich bin der festen überzeugung dass der
finanzminister wenn er dann zusammen
rechnet was einzelne vorschläge auf sich
haben das natürlich auch gut bedenkt so
dass natürlich auch das ein großes
volumen wird haben müssen ich bin ja
auch jemand der gerade gesagt hat wir
können uns nicht nur mit einem schritt
begnügen und wenn es um einen schritt
geht da müssen wir ihnen genau auch nach
der sozialen balance auch entscheiden
und das eben auch menschen davon etwas
haben die möglicherweise noch stärkere
belastung in den nächsten monaten
bekommen deswegen habe ich auch den
heizkostenzuschuss als ein element was
wir aus dem koalitionsausschuss
herangetragen genannt zum zweiten ich
bin mir ganz sicher dass die
regierungschefs ihre reise auch unter
sicherheitsbedingungen gut vor geplant
haben jedes zeichen an die ukraine an
die ukrainische regierung an die dortige
bevölkerung die unter massiven beschuss
in unterschiedlichen teilen des landes
nicht nur leidet sondern zivilisten
tagtäglich tag stündlich um kommen ist
wichtig ob bei diesen gesprächen
möglicherweise auch das zur sprache
kommt was zurzeit die ukrainische seite
mit der russischen seite erörtert wäre
durchaus wichtig auch zu wissen und ich
schätze immer jeden direkten austausch
wenn er auch unter den rahmenbedingungen
möglich ist herr schäfer
wenn sie sagen der freihändige vorschlag
des finanzministers sagt ihn nicht so
richtig zu was würden sie denn konkret
vorschlagen über das hinaus was sie was
sie eben ja auch nochmal geschildert
haben ich hätte mir gewünscht dass der
bundesfinanzminister mit uns gemeinsam
in der koalition und in der
bundesregierung einen abgestimmten
vorschlag auf die strecke bringt
deswegen ist es gut dass wir uns jetzt
darauf verständigt haben dass alle drei
koalitionsparteien aus den jeweiligen
ebenen insgesamt drei expertinnen und
experten
benennen die relativ schnell am liebsten
in den nächsten tagen ein umfassendes
paket auf den weg bringen und das wäre
dann nicht frei hin nicht sondern das
wäre belastbar und konzentriert
rolf mützenich der vorsitzender der
spd-fraktion ganz am anfang hat er
gewiss darauf hingewiesen dass rainer
hoffmann heute zu gast ist in der
fraktion quasi auf abschiedsbesuch
nachfolger des die nachfolgerin des igb
vorsitzenden wird bekanntermaßen jasmin
fach chemie noch mitglied der spd
bundestagsfraktion wir schauen auf
bündnis 90/die grünen beziehungsweise
deren fraktionen hier im deutschen
bundestag da gibt es im moment so eine
stimmung zwischen feiern und verdruss
feiern auf der einen seite das 200
milliarden paket für klimaschutz und
energiesicherheit auf der anderen seite
steht das 100 milliarden pakete
sogenannte sondervermögen für die
bundeswehr und die für die aufrüstung
was vielen grünen aber auch eine reihe
von sozialdemokraten durchaus schwer im
magen liegt zumal man noch nicht ganz
genau weiß wofür diese mittel zu
verwenden oder wofür diese mittel dann
ganz konkret verwendet werden sollen und
das ist dann doch für viele
sozialdemokratinnen aber auch für viele
mitglieder der fraktion von bündnis 90
die grünen einer die äußerst schwer
verdauliche angelegenheit da wird es
sicherlich noch die eine und andere
diskussion geben britta haßelmann die
vorsitzende der fraktion bündnis 90 die
grünen hat sich ja auch geäußert heute
über das thema entlastung für
insbesondere
autofahrerinnen aber auch für
bürgerinnen und bürger die jetzt erhöhte
kosten haben durch energiepreise also
auch fürs heizen und für den strom
zunächst hat sie aber auch nochmal auf
den krieg in der ukraine geblickt
natürlich ist der angriffskrieg von
putin die brutalität und die grausamkeit
dieses krieges mit der geführt wird
gegen die zivilbevölkerung
das zentrale alles beherrschende thema
wir versuchen nach wie vor als
bundestagsfraktionen die bundesregierung
darin zu stützen
sanktionen
waffenlieferung auch europäische und
transatlantische im g7 kontext weitere
scharfe sanktionen auf dem weg zu
bringen
und darüber unsere solidarität mit der
ukraine zu bekunden das ist furchtbar
es ist besorgniserregend und wir wissen
dass die menschen
die aus der ukraine fliehen können
unsere volle unterstützung und aufnahme
brauchen wir sind sehr froh dass es
bisher im europäischen kontext so gut
gelingt die bereitschaft der
europäischen staaten ist groß darüber
sind wir sehr froh hier wird man sich
jetzt weiter europäisch darüber
verständigen wie die verteilung die
aufnahme und unterstützung der
geflüchteten menschen aus der ukraine
insgesamt im europäischen kontext
aussehen kann wir sind auch sehr froh
über die hilfsbereitschaft die
unterstützung und das große anpacken
hier im land die hilfsbereitschaft der
bürgerinnen und bürger der
zivilgesellschaft des thw ist der
rettungsdienste vieler organisation
wohlfahrtsverbände und auch staatlichen
stellen und das hand in hand arbeiten
führt dazu dass wir insbesondere den
frauen und kindern die aus der ukraine
fliehen konnten hier aufnahme schutz und
unterstützung bieten können das ist
wirklich ein ganz wichtiges signal
und hier geht es jetzt darum uns auch
für die nächsten wochen und monate gut
aufeinander abgestimmt
miteinander zwischen bund ländern und
kommunen den wohlfahrtsverbänden und
hilfsorganisationen zu agieren und
deshalb halten wir es auch für wichtig
dass wir einen gipfel hier im
bundeskanzleramt um all diese hilfen all
diese strukturen die da sind gut
ineinander verzahnt zur wirksamkeit zu
bringen ein zweiter punkt über den wir
in dieser parlamentarischen woche und in
den fraktionen diskutieren ist das
entlastungspaket was in dieser woche auf
den weg gebracht wird im kabinett
gerade angesichts der hohen abhängigkeit
fossile energien der steigenden
energiepreise der steigenden
lebenshaltungskosten
ist es sehr wichtig bürgerinnen und
bürger zu entlasten
und mit dem ersten entlastungspaket auf
das wir uns in der ampel verständigt
haben was ein einmal zuschlag der
grundsicherung ein sofort zuschlag für
kinder steuerliche entlastung und
weitere elemente wie die abschaffung der
eeg-umlage vorsieht ist ein wichtiger
erster schritt getan frage ist für die
grünen lindner tank rabatt vorschlag
überhaupt kein gangbarer weg gehen sie
davon aus dass es schon morgen zu
beschlüssen kommen kann oder braucht die
zuständige arbeitsgruppe noch etwas zeit
fragt herr heller
also jetzt ist es ja ein ganz normaler
weg dass die ampel partnerinnen und
partner sich darüber verständigen welche
vorschläge und ideen sind dafür ein
zweites entlastungspaket ich habe gerade
deutlich gemacht unser vorschlag wird
der eines energie geldes sein es gibt
andere vorschläge wie etwa der von
christian lindner zum tank rabatt ich
glaube jeder vorschlag der gemacht wird
muss ich den kriterien nachhaltig sozial
und ökologisch
dem muss her standhalten können in der
abwägung mich überzeugt dass bisher
nicht dass das der vorschlag zum tank
rabatt die änderungen des
infektionsschutzgesetzes grünen hätten
sich noch ein bisschen mehr vorstellen
können oder noch mehr maßnahmen aufrecht
zu erhalten jetzt gab es gestern bei der
anhörung im gesundheitsausschuss bei der
expertenanhörung große kritik daran
viele virologen epidemiologe haben
gesagt rafften pflicht beispielsweise
als basis maßnahme müsste man eigentlich
beibehalten ihr grüner
gesundheitsexperte jens spahn fordert
auch noch nachbesserungen wie
optimistisch sind sie denn dass diese
woche noch mal an diesem gesetzentwurf
nachgebessert werden könnte ja also wir
als fraktion und unsere
die gestern an der anhörung teilgenommen
haben haben die einwände und kritik am
gesetzentwurf
deutlich wahrgenommen und wissen selbst
dass sie im hinblick auf die frage einer
allgemeinen masken pflicht in
innenräumen dass zb etwas wäre was wir
unterstützt hätten ich habe aber klar
gesagt die abwägung für uns ist die gibt
es am ende
eine weitere gesetzliche regelung die
einen basisschutz vorsieht oder laufen
diese regelung aus
und deshalb wir hätten uns hier eine
vorausschauende und
auch durch mehr maßen haben
basismaßnahmen gestützte entwurf
vorgestellt das war aber in der
koalition mit einem der drei partner
nicht möglich
britta haßelmann co vorsitzende der
fraktion bündnis 90 die grünen mit den
themen die ihr an diesem heutigen tag
wichtig sind und sie haben es gemerkt
das sind die themen die uns die ganze
zeit schon begleiten auf der einen seite
der krieg in der ukraine und die folgen
insbesondere die diskussion wie können
autofahrerinnen autofahrer wir können
aber auch die bürger und bürgerinnen
insgesamt entlastet werden durch die
steigenden energiekosten der bitte
koalition in den nächsten tagen noch
einiges zu diskutieren haben und das
andere große thema in diesem tag und in
dieser woche im bundestag eben auch
corona maßnahmen die änderung des
infektionsschutzgesetzes
aber auch das thema impfpflicht und die
gruppenanträge die am donnerstag das
erste mal diskutiert werden im
zusammenhang mit dem thema ukraine
vielleicht noch ein kleiner hinweis am
donnerstagmorgen um 9 uhr erwarten die
abgeordneten im plenum eine live
schaltung zu wolodimir selensky dem
präsidenten der ukraine
das sollte eigentlich schon am
vergangenen freitag stattgefunden haben
im bundesrat man hat das dann verschoben
auch aus technischen gründen und diese
ansprache des präsidenten wird nun am
kommenden
an diesem donnerstag erwartet sie merken
ich ziehe ein ganz klein wenig in dem
was ich erzähle den wir warten auf die
beiden vorsitzenden der unionsfraktion
friedrich merz auf der einen seite und
der vorsitzende der csu landesgruppe
alexander dobrindt die sind
offensichtlich auf dem weg wenn ich
jetzt so sein glück gucken würde könnte
sie aussehen aber ich glaube sie haben
ihren platz in dieser sekunde auch
erreicht kurzer blick mal nach hinten
und deswegen gebe ich ab an die andere
kamera und wir hören rein in das
statement der beiden unions chefs hier
im bundestag bundestag alexander
dobrindt
ja meine damen und herren grüße sie alle
sehr herzlich freue mich dass wir uns
sehen auch wenn es schwere zeiten sind
wir haben in dieser woche eigentlich ein
datum im terminkalender stehen das für
die opposition ein gutes datum sein
könnte einmal eine zwischenbilanz der
bisherigen
regierungsarbeit vorzunehmen nämlich am
kommenden freitag 100 tage ampel aber
dieses datum geht natürlich ein bisschen
verloren tritt in den hintergrund im
schatten des krieges den wir in der
ukraine mit unverminderter ja sogar
gesteigerter härte erleben dieser krieg
beschwert uns beschäftigt uns und es ist
auch das wesentliche thema vermutlich in
dieser woche dass wir im deutschen
bundestag zu behandeln haben wir sind
mit einer zunehmend großen zahl von
flüchtlingen in deutschland konfrontiert
die flüchtlinge kommen in deutschland an
auf der grundlage der massen zu sturms
richtlinie der europäischen union
das heißt sie haben in deutschland nach
dem aufenthaltsgesetz einen
aufenthaltstitel was aber nicht heißt
dass man den flüchtlingsstrom nicht auch
etwas ordnen muss und auch kanalisieren
muss wir sehen hier die flüchtlinge an
vielen bahnhöfen in deutschland ankommen
ohne jede unterstützung und ohne jede
hilfe des bundes nur zur erinnerung der
bund ist zuständig für die bahnhöfe das
gehört in den
zuständigkeitsbereich der
bundesministerium des inneren sie hätte
eigentlich schon längst das tun müssen
was wir von ihr in der letzten woche
bereits an dieser stelle
erwartet haben nämlich einen krisen und
koordinierungsstab mit den ländern und
den kommunen einzurichten sie hält das
bis heute nicht für notwendig und
dementsprechend erfolgt der zustrom der
flüchtlinge dieser kriegsflüchtlinge aus
der ukraine mehr oder weniger ohne jede
unterstützung und hilfe des bundes es
spielen sich hier chaotische szenen an
den bahnhöfen ab wir müssen damit
rechnen dass in den nächsten tagen und
wochen die zahl der flüchtlinge noch
einmal drastisch zunimmt unter diesen
flüchtlingen sind nach unseren
einsichten und erkenntnissen
mittlerweile eine größere zahl von
flüchtlingen die gar nicht aus der
ukraine kommen sondern sich über diesen
weg jetzt auch nach deutschland gemacht
haben wir fordern die
bundesinnenministerium jetzt wirklich
auf sich um dieses thema zu kümmern und
vor allem dafür zu sorgen dass die
flüchtlinge registriert werden so wie
das zum beispiel an der ukrainisch
polnischen grenze erfolgt wo das auf der
basis modernster
datenverarbeitungssysteme sehr
erfolgreich vorgenommen wird das zweite
große thema was uns in dieser woche
beschäftigen wird ist die
energieversorgung in deutschland die
energiepreise schießen durch die decke
wie erneuern in dieser woche den
vorschlag die energiepreise in
deutschland zu dämpfen und zwar auf zwei
wegen erstens indem in deutschland die
mehrwertsteuer auf zeit von 19 auf 7
prozent gesenkt wird das hätte an den
tankstellen eine sofortige wirkung um
etwa 20 prozent niedrigeren spritkosten
wir wollen aber auch den vorschlag
machen und erneuern auch die energie
steuer zu senken also das was früher die
mineralölsteuer war um 20 cent pro liter
dies würde insbesondere diejenigen
helfen die nicht vor steuer abzugsfähig
sind also kleinen handwerksbetrieben
speditions betrieben und vielen anderen
die jetzt dringend hilfe brauchen für
die wirklich sehr schwer gewordene
versorgung der bevölkerung
das dritte thema ist ein thema das uns
seit dem 27 februar beschäftigt nämlich
die frage wie eigentlich die zukunft der
bundeswehr aussieht sie alle erinnern
sich der bundeskanzler hat in seiner
regierungserklärung am 27 februar
vorgeschlagen 100 milliarden euro
zusätzlich für die bundeswehr und
dauerhaft das ziel von zwei prozent zu
erreichen und zu über schreiten ich will
den satz noch mal vorlesen den der
bundeskanzler in seiner
regierungserklärung gesagt hat wörtlich
wir werden von nun an also 2022 jahr für
jahr mehr als zwei prozent des bip in
unsere verteidigung investieren das ist
der entscheidende satz seiner
regierungserklärung im hinblick auf die
bundeswehr wir haben heute mehr als zwei
wochen nach dieser regierungserklärung
die ersten schriftlichen unterlagen aus
der bundesregierung bekommen und diese
unterlagen sind im grunde nicht mehr und
nicht weniger als die aussetzung der
schuldenbremse für weitere 100
milliarden euro anders kann man den text
nicht interpretieren eine änderung des
grundgesetzes ein gesetzentwurf für die
errichtung eines zusätzlichen und neuen
sondervermögens für die bundeswehr das
kann alles einfach gesetzlich geregelt
werden das einzige was eine zweidrittel
mehrheit im deutschen bundestag
erfordert ist diese änderung des
grundgesetzes wir haben heute morgen mit
den beiden arbeitsgruppen haushalt und
verteidigung bereits ausführlich darüber
beraten wir hatten einen
parlamentarischen staatssekretär aus der
bundesregierung aus dem
bundesfinanzministerium zu gast der das
sehr ausführlich und sehr offen auch
erläutert hat wir haben die diskussionen
begonnen ich hoffe dass die
bundesregierung bereit ist über diese
texte noch einmal wirklich ausführlich
zu sprechen so jedenfalls wie wir sie
jetzt vorliegen haben sind sie für uns
nicht zustimmungsfähig wir wollen
insbesondere auch den dauerhaften
bestand von 2% plus sehen und nicht nur
einmalig mit 100 milliarden das wäre
umgerechnet etwa vier bis fünf jahre
ausreichend aber nicht dauerhaft und wir
wollen vor allem an den
beschaffungsvorhaben beteiligt werden
wir wollen wissen was die
bundesregierung denn dann tatsächlich in
den nächsten jahren beschaffen will um
die bündnisse und landesverteidigung
aufrecht zu erhalten wir sehen mit
großem respekt die reise von drei
europäischen staats und regierungschefs
nach kiew heute die regierungschefs aus
polen aus der tschechei und aus der
slowakei moretti fiala und ja und jansa
reiten horizon heute hat nicht reisen
heute reisen heute nach kiew
mit allergrößtem respekt was diese drei
regierungschefs da auch an persönlichem
risiko aufzunehmen um die solidarität
nicht nur der drei länder sondern auch
der gesamten europäischen union noch
einmal zu unterstreichen wir hätten uns
gewünscht dass im deutschen bundestag
wenigstens in dieser woche einmal die
gelegenheit bestanden hätte über eine
regierungserklärung der bundesregierung
eine diskussion zu führen wie es in
diesem konflikt und wie sie mit der
bewältigung dieses konflikts jetzt
weitergeht die koalition hat eine
aktuelle stunde für morgen nachmittag
beantragt wir werden am donnerstagmorgen
eine rede oder eine kurze ein kurzes
statement des
ukrainischen staatspräsidenten
live übertragen bekommen in die in das
plenum des deutschen bundestages also am
donnerstagmorgen zur sogenannten
kernzeit und anschließend wir haben es
leider nicht ändern können will die
koalition nun unmittelbar nach dieser
erklärung im deutschen bundestag die
impfpflicht diskutieren wir empfinden
das als völlig unpassend wir hätten
erwartet dass nach diesem statement des
ukrainischen präsidenten der
bundeskanzler eine regierungserklärung
abgibt auch im hinblick auf die
ergebnisse des sonder rates der
europäischen staats und regierungschefs
in der letzten woche das ist eigentlich
gute übung das entweder vorher oder
nachher ein regierungschef auch im
deutschen bundestag hier eine
regierungserklärung abgibt und wir
anschließend eine debatte im plenum
gehabt hätten die koalition hat sich
leider geweigert eine solche
tagesordnung zu ermöglichen wir bedauern
das sehr und werden deswegen an anderer
stelle dann auch unsere punkte zur
sprache bringen es gibt eine ganze reihe
von anträgen zu diesen drei punkten die
ich ihnen eben genannt habe jetzt auch
im deutschen bundestag vorliegen ja so
weit wird die sitzungswoche dann in
dieser woche ihren lauf nehmen noch
einmal beschwert und für uns alle auch
persönlich belastend diese bilder die
wir aus den kriegsgebieten sehen womit
nochmals gesteigerter härte ein
verbrecherischer krieg gegen die
zivilbevölkerung
dieses landes geführt wird wie alle
hoffen dass wir eine chance haben diesen
krieg möglichst schnell dem ende
entgegen zu sehen aber
das ist eine hoffnung und alles andere
als ein gewisser
friedrich merz der vorsitzende der
unionsfraktion im deutschen bundestag
und jetzt hat der so viel zeit
verbraucht das wir alexander dobrindt
zumindest an dieser stelle gar nicht
mehr zu wort kommen lassen weil nämlich
sonst das ganze schöne gefüge das wir
aufgebaut haben in dieser
dreiviertelstunde rund um die
stellungnahmen der fraktionen
auseinanderbrechen würde ja er
reklamiert dass es keine debatte gibt
nach der schalter zu wolodimir selensky
diese debatte wird es in der tat angeben
morgen am mittwoch in einer aktuellen
stunde und das thema ukraine wird dann
auch noch mal dem thema seien nämlich in
einer aktuellen stunde die unions
fraktion beantragt hat da sind
allerdings die flüchtlinge im
mittelpunkt wir schauen auf die fpd
fdp-fraktion der wirt der
bundesfinanzminister und
parteivorsitzende christian lindner in
diesen tagen von dem einen und anderen
heftig kritisiert für seinen vorschlag
eines tankwarts der vorsitzende der fdp
bundestagsfraktion christian doerr der
hat in diesem vorschlag heute verteidigt
aber hat zu beginn seiner stellungnahme
auch zunächst mal ihnen die ukraine
geblickt
das erste ist natürlich das wichtigste
nach wie vor auch in dieser woche
nämlich der krieg den russland gegen die
ukraine führt wir sehen nach wie vor
schlecht schreckliche bilder die uns bis
ins mark erschüttern ich denke
beispielsweise an die zerstörte
kinderklinik in mario pohl und die
betroffenen menschen vor ort das wird
natürlich unsere herzen auch hier in
deutschland
gleichzeitig sehen wir dass immer mehr
menschen die ukraine verlassen
verständlicherweise wir sehen immer mehr
geflüchtete und deswegen freue ich mich
dass die solidarität der menschen in
deutschland groß ist und wir unseren
beitrag dazu leisten diesen menschen
zuflucht zu bieten meine damen und
herren an dieser stelle es mir wichtig
dass wir die koordinierung der
flüchtlingswelle auch hinbekommen
ganz wichtig an der stelle ist auch das
was volker wissing gemacht der hat ja
polen besucht und hat dort entsprechend
auch koordiniert und sich den einsatz
dort angeschaut das ehrenamt vor ort das
gleiche gilt natürlich auch deutschland
und an dieser stelle möchte ich sagen
dass sich auch von der bundes
innenministerin erwartet dass sie dort
jedenfalls die koordinierung weiter
verstärkt insbesondere mit den
bundesländern wir hören aus den kommunen
in deutschland das dort hier auch eine
nationale koordinierung von nöten ist
und an der stelle müssen wir weiter
unsere arbeit auch als bundesregierung
intensivieren meiner meinung nach
richtig ist auch dass wladimir putin und
sein regime einen hohen preis zahlen für
diesen angriffskrieg es gibt
mittlerweile eine waren knappheit in
russland und gleichzeitig ist ein tausch
auch in harte devisen der nationalen
währung des rubels nicht mehr möglich
das abschneiden der russischen notenbank
war ein ganz ganz wichtiger schritt der
jetzt immer mehr wirkt wir sehen dass
beispielsweise an den ratingagenturen
die mittlerweile russische
staatsanleihen als ramsch anleihen
bezeichnen der krieg in der ukraine hat
natürlich auch finanzielle auswirkungen
für die menschen bei uns im land
insbesondere die auto fahren autofahrer
sind massiv von gestiegenen spritpreisen
betroffen und lasse mich 1
in diesem zusammenhang einordnen
die ampelkoalition
hat hier ein doppeltes erbe von der
ehemaligen unionsgeführten
bundesregierung angetreten das eine ist
die abhängigkeit von russischen
rohstoffen sie wissen dass wir in der
bundesregierung daran arbeiten davon
loszukommen das ziel muss sein dass wir
unabhängiger werden von russischem
energieimporten und das zweite ist auch
in der vergangenheit auch vor diesem
konflikt war deutschland ein energie
höchstpreis land wir hatten erhebliche
belastungen in der für die menschen der
vergangenheit schon insofern trifft es
jetzt an allererster stelle die
autofahrern autofahrer aber alle
bürgerinnen und bürger beispielsweise
bei der wärmeversorgung besonders hart
und deswegen ist es richtig dass wir als
ampelkoalition hier auch auf entlastung
jetzt setzen
deswegen bin ich froh dass wir gemeinsam
mit sozialdemokraten und grünen ein
erstes entlastungspaket ja bereits
politisch vereinbart haben wir werden
fast 16 euro an entlastung auf den weg
bringen in den kommenden wochen und
genauso richtig ist dass wir jetzt über
weitere entlastung sprechen und in
diesem zusammenhang ja hat ja der
bundesfinanzminister christian lindner
wie ich finde einen sehr pragmatischen
vorschlag gemacht der tank rabatt den er
vorschlägt würde zu einer direkten
entlastung der autofahrer und autofahrer
und insbesondere der pendler in
deutschland führen die ja um ihren
arbeitsplatz aufzusuchen auf das auto
angewiesen sind das sage ich als
niedersachse insbesondere auch im
ländlichen raum und dieser pragmatische
vorschlag ist einfach umzusetzen er
würde dazu führen dass an der ladenkasse
der tankstelle direkt ein rabatt
abgezogen wird es würde dann mit den
mineralölkonzern verrechnet insofern
entsteht keinerlei bürokratie es wäre
schnell umzusetzen und die entlastung
würde bei den autofahrern und
autofahrern sofort an kommt der dritte
punkt den ich anspreche möchte ist
natürlich die korona pandemie die uns
nach wie vor beschäftigt
dass sie der freien demokraten war dass
wir sukzessive zur normalität in
deutschland zurückkehren und deswegen
haben wir werden wir in dieser woche
einen infektionsschutzgesetz eine
änderung auf den weg bringen in der
vergangenheit war die grundlage für
einschränkungen in deutschland immer
eine mögliche überbelastung des
gesundheitswesens das ist jetzt
glücklicherweise nicht mehr der fall wir
haben zwar hohe inzidenz aber
gleichzeitig keine überlastung der
krankenhäuser glücklicherweise und wenn
es eben diese grundlage nicht mehr gibt
nämlich eine überlastung des
gesundheitssystems da müssen auch
freiheits einschränkungen zurückgenommen
werden und dann müssen wir auf mehr
eigenverantwortung der menschen in
deutschland setzen gleichwohl kann es
sinnvoll sein dass die länder
beispielsweise für den öpnv oder für den
schutz von wohngruppen in alten- und
pflegeeinrichtungen weiterhin dinge
anordnen können ich denke beispielsweise
an die tests pflichten die auch im
gesetz stehen oder an masken pflichten
in solchen einrichtungen darüber hinaus
haben wir den wunsch der
ministerpräsidenten aufgenommen für eine
sogenannte hot spot regelung dabei geht
es darum den einzelnen
gebietskörperschaften
vor der situation stehen das vor eine
überbelastung des gesundheitssystems
droht dass man dann auch weitergehende
maßnahmen einführen kann insofern halte
ich den zwischen dem
bundesjustizminister marco buschmann und
dem bundesgesundheitsminister karl
lauterbach ausgehandelten kompromiss für
einen sehr guten kompromiss
christian dürr der vorsitzende der
fdp-fraktion im bundestag und ob das mit
der normalität tatsächlich alles so
aufgeht wie er sich das zumindest
wünscht und in aussicht stellt das wären
dann den nächsten 14 tage bis vier
wochen zeigen viele bundesländer haben
schon angekündigt dass sie die
möglichkeiten von übergangsfristen also
die jetzigen regelungen bestehen lassen
bis mindestens zweiter april auch
bestehen lassen wollen und dann ist
natürlich die möglichkeit dar dass die
bundesländer entsprechend ihrer hotspot
lage auch weitergehende beschlüsse
fassen können als das was am freitag
hier im infektionsschutzgesetz einen
gezielten an sogenannten basis maßnahmen
verabschiedet werden wird auch der
bundesrat wird übrigens am freitag noch
zu einer sondersitzung zusammenkommen
und über dieses gesetz dann noch einmal
beschließen wir schauen auf die aber die
fraktionen hier im deutschen bundestag
um die partei ist es in den vergangenen
tagen etwas ruhiger geworden das mag auf
der einen seite damit zusammenhängen
dass man sich den einen oder anderen
gedanken macht über die bisherige
unverhohlene sympathie für russlands
präsident putin da ist ja doch einiges
jetzt ins rutschen gekommen und
möglicherweise wird er auch die eine und
andere rolle rückwärts nötig das ist der
eine grund der sein könnte der andere
grund könnte auch damit zusammenhängen
dass das verwaltungsgericht köln vor gut
fünf tagen entschieden hatte dass die
afg vom verfassungsschutz als
verdachtsfall betrachtet werden kann
also dass
verfassungsschutz maßnahmen ergriffen
werden können die partei unter
bestimmten regeln unter bestimmten
bedingungen auch intensiver beobachtet
werden kann und zwar in gänze nicht nur
einzelne teile ihrer partei
heute hat sich geäußert vor der
fraktionssitzung der fdp deren co
vorsitzender timo kruppa und seine
ersten ausführungen gehalten dem thema
im pflicht zum einen der einrichtungs
bezogenen aber auch der allgemeinen
impfpflicht liga auf und oder nach
wunsch vieler abgeordneter hier im
parlament durchaus bald mal kommen soll
sehr geehrte pressevertreter herzlich
willkommen von meiner seite drei themen
die die parlamentswoche beschäftigt aber
auch natürlich unsere bürger ist zum
einen die einrichtungs bezogene
impfpflicht die allgemeine impfpflicht
da wissen wir dass ab morgen in
deutschland die einrichtungs bezogen
eine impfpflicht gilt und das ist ein
schlechter tag für die freiheit in
deutschland durch die einrichtungs
bezogene impfpflicht gehen jetzt
massenhaft weitere fachkräfte verloren
die krise im gesundheitssektor wird
damit auch auf die spitze getrieben die
einrichtungs bezogene entspricht muss
deshalb sofort zurückgenommen werden wie
auch alle übrigen einschränkungen der
grundrechte
eine impfpflicht darf es weder für
bestimmte berufsgruppen noch für
bestimmte altersgruppen aber auch nicht
für alle bürger geben einzig die fdp
fraktion steht weiterhin geschlossen zu
diesem versprechen
unserer haltung zum impfen ist klar
freiheit statt zwang das war unser
versprechen vor der bundestagswahl und
auch nach der bundestagswahl der zweite
thema sind die korona maßnahmen so
genannte basisschutz der auch die woche
zum thema ist ab 20 märz muss auch
deutschland endlich sein tag der
freiheit haben eine verstetigung vor dem
grundrechts einschränkenden
ausnahmeregelungen unter dem
euphemistischen begriff basisschutz
lehnt die fdp fraktion ab wir fordern
die bundesregierung in unserem antrag
deshalb auf die grundrechts
einschränkung des
infektionsschutzgesetzes
ersatzlos aufzuheben es muss in der
eigenverantwortung der bürger liegen ob
und welche schutzmaßnahmen sie in freier
entscheidung treffen wollen so wie es im
übrigen in vielen anderen europäischen
ländern mittlerweile usus ist ganz
besonders wichtig ist in diesem
zusammenhang dass wir die schüler
umgehend deutschlandweit von masken
zwang erlösen gerade für kinder ist eine
massen pflicht durch nichts zu
rechtfertigen zum dritten punkt
russland ukraine krieg auch zum krieg in
der ukraine hat ja auf die fraktion auf
ihrer klausurtagung vergangene woche ein
positionspapier beschlossen es umfasst
folgende punkte ich möchte einige punkte
auch da kurz vorstellen wir verurteilen
darin den völkerrechtswidrigen
angriffskrieg russlands fordern einen
sofortigen waffenstillstand
und bekunden unsere trauer um die
zivilen opfer und die gefallenen
soldaten auf beiden seiten ein beitritt
der ukraine zur eu und zur nato lehnen
wir ebenso ab wie waffenlieferung in
kriegsgebiete
wir leben ebenso ab
wirtschaftssanktionen hauptsächlich noch
solche die uns selbst dann am meisten
betreffen auch an nordstream 2 halten
wir fest und setzen und zweiter im
bundestag für den wiedereinstieg
demzufolge auch der kernenergie aus was
zur energiesicherheit auch deutschlands
fundamental wichtig ist so wie auch den
weiterbetrieb der moderne
kohlekraftwerke
wir befürworten sanktionen die sich
gegen verantwortliche und unterstützer
des angriffskriegs berichten lehnen
diskriminierungen große sprache ihrer
mitbürger ab und treten auch diesen
entschieden entgegen die temporäre
aufnahme ukrainischer kriegsflüchtlinge
befürworte die fw-fraktion sofern es
sich um ukrainische staatsbürger auch
handelt auch hier müssen diese person
egal welcher nation natürlich
kontrollierten auch registriert werden
was aktuell noch nicht in vollem umfang
geschieht zu den teuerungen denken kino
copala für die afg fraktion
beziehungsweise fehlt uns jetzt nur noch
die stellungnahme der co-vorsitzenden
aus der linksfraktion das ist amira
mohammed ali auch sie hat sich mit dem
thema ukraine krieg beschäftigt aber
auch mit den folgen die da die das ganze
zeitigt und aber zunächst einblick in
die ukraine
ich beginne mit der ja mit dem
drängendsten nämlich dem krieg in der
ukraine
die lage ist entsetzlich also dieser
völkerrechtswidriger angriffskrieg
von putin der tobias nun schon seit über
zwei wochen immer mehr menschen sterben
darunter auch viele viele zivilisten
zivilisten
millionen menschen müssen flüchten man
sieht zerstörte gebäude ist natürlich
straßen das ist einfach grauenvoll und
dazu sage ich erneut dieser krieg muss
sofort beendet werden es muss alle
notwendige humanitäre hilfe sofort
geleistet werden wir brauchen eine
friedliche lösung wir müssen zurück
kehren zum völkerrecht zu diplomatie
das ist jetzt wichtig und klar ist in
einer solchen schrecklichen situation
dass die demokratischen fraktionen des
deutschen bundestages jetzt gemeinsam
eben alles dafür tun müssen dass dieser
krieg möglichst bald beendet wird und
unsere aufgabe oppositionsfraktion ist
es die maßnahmen der bundesregierung
dafür kritisch zu begleiten und auch zu
hinterfragen und
deswegen möchte ich zu zwei maßnahmen
wir etwas sagen einmal das
sondervermögen für die bundeswehr von
100 milliarden euro und eben das
erreichen des nato 2 prozent ziels
prozent des bruttoinlandsproduktes soll
für militär ausgegeben werden das hat
olaf scholz bei der sondersitzung
angekündigt
und beides sehen wir als linke kritisch
und nicht zu sagen in der deutlichkeit
wir lehnen das ab denn man muss sehen
dass die nato staaten bereits jetzt mehr
als das 15 fache ausgeben für militär
als russland das tut und man muss eben
feststellen dass dass russland nicht
davor abgeschreckt hat diesen
schrecklichen krieg zu beginnen also wie
kommt man darauf dass in zukunft ein
gegenseitiges hochrüsten zu mehr frieden
führen soll die geschichte lehrt uns in
großer deutlichkeit dass aufrüstung
spiralen eben nicht zum frieden führen
sondern eben zum gegenteil und ja wir
wissen die bundeswehr ist nicht
vernünftig ausgestattet für den
verteidigungsfall und das und übrigens
nur das ist ihre aufgabe
nach unserem grundgesetz
aber woran liegt das dass die bundeswehr
nicht vernünftig ausgestattet ist liegt
das wirklich daran dass zu wenig geld da
ist und die antwort ist klar nein wenn
der aktuelle militär etat beträgt fast
50 milliarden euro geld das
offensichtlich größtenteils irgendwo
versickert in diesen tagen sind
natürlich energiepreise die gehen immer
weiter durch die decke viele menschen
haben große probleme sich den sprit
stars und den strom überhaupt noch
leisten zu können das normale leben wird
für immer mehr menschen unbezahlbar
es ist dringend notwendig dass die
bundesregierung jetzt die bürgerinnen
und bürger durch entsprechende maßnahmen
sofort spürbar entlastet und was
christian lender jetzt tun möchte mit im
tank rabatt das mag ist auf den ersten
blick vielleicht ganz gut klingen aber
es ist einfach das falsche instrument
denn für viele tankstellenbetreiber ist
es überhaupt nicht möglich mit großen
summen ist erst mal in vorleistung zu
gehen und dann nach längerer zeit mit
wahrscheinlich unter bürokratischen
hürden sie einen betrag erstatten zu
lassen und es ist auch noch völlig
unklar wie hoch dieser rabatt sein soll
20 und 40 cent wenn die spritpreise so
weiter steigen dann muss man auch zum
ergebnis kommen dann wird das nicht
besonders viel bringen außerdem ist es
wenn überhaupt wenn überhaupt eine
einzelmaßnahme die den spritpreis
geringfügig reduzieren würde aber das
reicht nicht aus wir brauchen insgesamt
eine entlastung bei allen energiekosten
und deswegen ist es richtig das zu tun
was wir fordern nämlich die
mehrwertsteuer abzusenken von neun von
17 auf 9 prozent wenn man das tut wurde
der liter benzin und diesel um fast
einen euro reduziert die kosten dafür
dass eine deutliche entlastung und hören
beim strompreis entsprechen die
mehrwertsteuer senkt und auch die co2
steuer absenkt auch da wären möglich
wäre dass maßnahmen die den strompreis
um ein viertel ab senken würden das wäre
dringend notwendig die entsprechenden
ergebnisse hätten wir auch beim klima
gar amira mohammed ali co vorsitzende
der fraktion die linke hier im deutschen
bundestag und das linke und union in
sachen steuern mal hand in hand
diskutieren das hätte man vor einiger
zeit auch nicht so wirklich erwartet
höchste zeit für einen kurzen schnellen
überblick über das was im plenum in
dieser woche noch passiert teilweise
haben wir sie ihnen ja auch schon
angedeutet morgen um 13 uhr also
zunächst mal die erste beratung des
infektionsschutzgesetzes beziehungsweise
dessen änderungen dann wird es eine
befragung der bundesinnenministerium
geben und später am nachmittag dann die
aktuelle stunde zur lage in der ukraine
donnerstagmorgen dann zugeschaltet live
und alle hoffen dass das gut
funktioniert auch technisch der
präsident der ukraine
wolodimir seelen ski und dann wird es im
anschluss geben die erste debatte über
das thema eben pflicht sie wissen es
gibt eine reihe von gruppen anträgen es
gibt aber auch anträge aus im moment
zumindest stand der dinge aus den reihen
der union und aus der ard da ist aber
noch einiges im fluss wir haben so unter
anderem auch von rolf mützenich gehört
und dann wie gesagt am dann war am
freitag zweiter und dritter beratung der
änderung des infektionsschutzgesetzes
und wenn das hier die mehrheit gefunden
hat wovon alle ausgehen dann wird das
ganze im bundesrat auch noch mal
abgestimmt und dann kann die gehen
können die gesetzesänderung in kraft
treten und dann werden wir ab
zwanzigster märz tatsächlich eine
zumindest formal leichtere lager haben
was die maßnahmen angeht aber auf der
anderen seite eben nach wie vor eine
sehr angespannte corona lage mit
incidents werden so hoch wie noch nie in
dieser gesamten pandemie und das wird
bedeuten dass es so ganz normal
tatsächlich dann noch nicht sein wird im
gegenteil einige länder denn die
maßnahmen wahrscheinlich sogar noch
anziehen das war es für den moment von
der fraktionsebene im bundestag von den
statements der fraktionsspitzen zu
aktuellen themen auch zu denen die im
plenum sind in dieser woche ich gebe
zurück zu einem jahr stehen ja und ich
bedanke mich ganz herzlich bei ihnen
erhard scherfer nach berlin ja liebe
zuschauer wir haben in sachen ukraine
vor einigen augenblicken auch nach einer
eilmeldung hereinbekommen und da heißt
es dass es ungefähr 2000 zivilen
fahrzeugen gelungen sein soll aus mario
pohl aus der seit zwei wochen heftig
umkämpften stadt am asowschen meer raus
zu kommen das wäre ja ein
hoffnungsschimmer und jetzt gehen wir
direkt weiter nach brüssel ich gucke mal
auf unserem aktuellen forscher monitor
da sehe ich schon nato-generalsekretär
ian stoltenberg mit einem aktuellen
statement und wir hören da mal rein
die ministerin und verteidigungsminister
werden sich morgen an einem bedeutenden
moment für unsere sicherheit treffen die
brutale